In five days steven
your identities
a mask to hide the scars
embrace it experience the sixth
episode of that only on disney plus
it's time stephen there he is hello man in
the mirror i know you're scared a bit yeah i
know you're confused you weren't supposed to see
any of this what are you sure you want to know
marc you look different i
can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
we protect the vulnerable and deliver justice
this is the best worst day of my life
really don't remember our adventures or
our life together oh god i wish i could
i don't know how to explain what's been happening
i can't tell the difference between life
and dreams all the things you've done brought you
to this moment embrace it you looked different
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new marvel moon knight trailer video there's a
lot of footage from episode 1 and the
other earlier episodes i think they
include a little bit of footage from later
on but not every single episode they're six
total i will be doing videos for all the
episodes we're doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships because it's starting this week
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave your favorite easter egg
from the trailers on the video to enter
also talk a little bit about what the actors have
said about the series being connected to other mcu
projects there's a little bit of confusion about
where this connects with everything else where all
the crossovers are going to happen and how this
references what's happening in the mcu right now
because there's a lot of really big stuff
happening we just saw the multiverse break
during spider-man no way home doctor strange kind
of fixed everything at the end with his big spell
the only difference with those particular
characters like the ones that showed up in the
cracks of reality is that they were characters
that knew that a version of peter parker was a
version of spider-man they're going to continue to
break reality in a much bigger way during doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness there's a bunch of
trailer footage of that that i've done videos for
but there's also thor 4 love and thunder there's a
lot of other stuff going on too so i will address
that during different parts of the video but a
lot of this brand new footage that we haven't
seen before mostly shows dr arthur harrow inside
this chamber inside this egyptian tomb where marc
spectre essentially dies and is reborn as moon
knight although this looks like it's happening
during a couple different places the way they shot
the series is kind of a rashaman style so you pick
up after his origin story but then you flash back
to the actual origin story so it jumps around
in the timeline of moon night quite a bit for the
most part they said that a lot of the present day
of the series after he's become moon knight takes
place in the london area but a lot of him actually
becoming the moon knight character takes place in
egypt like you see them in ancient egypt walking
across the sands walking into tombs looking at
all these artifacts you see him in this egyptian
temple falling into the water becoming a version
of moon knight so if you remember later in the
fight club movie when things got really crazy with
the way they played with perspective like who am i
right now am i the edward norton character or am
i tyler durden what's going on with tyler durden
it doesn't make any sense they're kind of taking
it in that direction the only difference in this
series is that a lot of the footage you see is
basically what you get during the series and
we're mostly just seeing in the trailers that it's
stephen grant and marc spector they're actually
two different versions of moon knight that people
have been talking about there's marc spector moon
knight like in the full costume with the wraps
over his head the crescent darts that he pulls
out of his chest the classic truncheon that you
see him wielding he pulls that from his back
that's what those two sticks are when you see
him beating people with the sticks the reason
why you don't see him using him in this scene here
when he turns around to the bus with the big grc
ad in the background is because they're
on his back but you also see him in the mr
knight persona which is sort of like the world's
greatest detective persona wearing the white suit
but it's still the moon knight costume
like it still forms the wraps around him
it just looks more like an actual suit and tie
that's sort of like the less hardcore version of
moon knight that he becomes when he's liaising
with police or when he's talking to people
when arthur harrow his henchmen start attacking
him when he gets into big fights he switches back
to the normal moonai persona but he can still
fight people when he's mr knight like you see
him holding the pieces of the truncheon here
the scene of him actually becoming moon knight
when he's inside this tomb here it looks like it's
before he's become moon knight for the first time
it's not totally clear when dr arthur harrow ethan
hawk's character finds out about the tomb here and
finds a way to enter it and use some of this god
power and the way that the notes about the show
talk about it the way they use the prop is that
even though you see it animated like it rises
up in his hand here it works a little bit like a
compass the way they show arthur harrow using all
the different type of powers also seems like he's
using the power of several different gods not just
a single god really good example is that you see
him with the tattoo on his arm that moves that's
a tattoo representing anubis the scales represent
the scales of life and death historically in the
egyptian faith as part of their mythology when
someone died their heart would be weighed by
anubis and they would have this feather test if it
would weigh more than the heart if it weighed less
than the heart and it was a way anubis controlled
who got into the version of the egyptian afterlife
there's a lot of other science fiction and
fantasy tv shows that have tried to use the god
in a different way he doesn't have that much of an
antagonistic relationship with the other egyptian
pantheon but remember this is the mcu the marvel
universe so arthur harrow could be using the power
of anubis for really bad things even if anubis
himself doesn't intend on trying to kill khonshu
or any of the other gods but that's the whole
reason why khonshu would want to stop dr arthur
harrow like he doesn't necessarily care about the
affairs of man he doesn't really care that much
about marc spector either only that marc spector
is a really good opportunity for him to actually
enact his will his vengeance on the mcu khonshu is
the egyptian moon god but the other members of his
pantheon are basically trapped in an alternate
dimension and they can only act inside the main
mcu dimension through avatars the whole idea with
arthur harrow is that he's kind of an avatar or at
least he's using the power of some of these other
egyptian gods there's a whole lot of footage of
khonshu taking marc spector in his mr knight
persona on this magical tour the multiverse
with his friend layla with them with her laptop
like she's typing trying to figure out what's
going on while it's all happening this seems
like khonshu trying to explain the cosmos like
everything in reality to marc spectre and why
it's so important for him to do what khonshu says
he's called the fist of khonshu because khonshu is
also meant to be the god of vengeance the way that
ethan hawk talked about his character too is it
because no villain actually thinks that they're
the villain they always think that they're in the
right ethan hawk's character at least the way he
played him in the series is that he's also trying
to get his own form of vengeance against the mcu
but he isn't really clear about what he's doing
in order to achieve that vengeance and why he
thinks that he needs vengeance even though doctor
strange gets really involved in cosmic characters
and cosmic goings-on in the mcu protecting the
mcu reality from threats from other dimensions
so he would theoretically be protecting earth or
watching earth against threats from these other
egyptian gods khonshu would kind of be on his
watch list but the whole idea when marc spector
becomes moon knight is the reason why khonshu
seems so obscure when you first hear about him is
because in the last several hundred years people
of egypt have stopped really caring about the
gods like with the advent of cell phones modern
technology people are worshiping that instead of
the traditional gods like they did in the olden
days the whole idea with gods in the mcu is that
they draw a lot of their power from the faith
of their followers it's a little bit different
when you talk about thor and the other asgardian
characters for instance because they're cosmic
characters who seem kind of like gods but they're
like little g gods that just call themselves gods
they're not really taking that approach with
kancho and the other egyptian pantheon like
they are meant to be legit gods they're not
like secretly aliens pretending to be gods
so the whole idea is that in present day people
started to forget about khonshu some of the other
gods they just became less and less powerful less
and less influential but that doesn't mean that
they're not powerful so when marc spector dies
in the right place at the right time khonshu sees
an opportunity to select a new avatar and says
look i can make you very powerful i have power
but i'm kind of limited in what i can do inside
this version of reality but recently the actors
have also been talking about the connections of
the other mcu projects right now so when they say
that this series is not as connected to the mcu
as some other stuff what they mean is that this
does take place in the mcu there are a lot of deep
connections to the mcu it's just that every five
seconds they don't reference the avengers in what
they're doing at any given moment it's a lot like
the black panther movie didn't spend a ton of
time after you get that sort of introduction to
sort of bridge things from civil war referencing
what the avengers are doing but even though the
moonlight series involves a lot of cosmic mcu
figures like gods the reason why people like
thor don't get involved because you think that he
would get involved with higher level cosmic things
is because when the moon knight series is going on
like i said most people don't care about khonshu
so he's not really on anyone's radar and presently
like while the events of moonite are going on he's
still off with the guardians of the galaxy the
events of thor love and thunder have not picked
up yet the series will have some sort of tag
scene or some moment at the end that addresses
werewolf by night because it's going to be sort of
a bridge character to mcu blade but for instance
supernatural creatures and characters in the mcu
werewolves and vampires have always existed in
the mcu they just been so low level so off the
radar that's why you haven't heard about them
in the mainstream marvel phase 1 phase 2 phase 3
movies they did kind of mention vampires during
thor ragnarok so they haven't mentioned vampires
they might actually be releasing episode 1 and
episode 2 this week instead of just episode 1 so
whatever they wind up releasing i will do full
episode videos for that make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that and
leave all your video requests in the comments
below if you have big questions about things
everyone click here for my new doctor strange
2 video with new footage and easter eggs
and click here for my other moon knight episode
1 video and learn about moon knight vs khonshu
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!